[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشفيق
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من جنين وهذه الصور
في اليوم الثاني لهجوم اسرائيليه امتد 88
ساعه على جنين واسفر عن استشهاد اثني عشر
فلس
طيني وهذه صور من كييف وبعد اعلان من وزير
الداخليه الاوكراني عن وقوع انفجار في
محكمه في العاصمه
ومقتل المنفذ على الفور
ومن العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم نرصد هذا
المشهد تزامنا مع احتدام المعارك في احياء
جنوب القرد
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد عمليه عسكريه في جنين استمرت يومين
واقرت اسرائيل بصعوبتها حماس تقول انسحاب
الاحتلال اعلان لعجزه عن تحقيق اهدافه
دمار واسع في جنين ومخيمها وانقطاع شبه
كلي للخدمات مكتب حقوق الانسان في الامم
المتحده يقول ان القصف الاسرائيلي
واستهداف المدنيين يرقى لجريمه حرب وفي تل
ابيب عوده مشهد الاحتجاجات ضد حكومه
نتنياهو والمتظاهرون يغلقون شوارع رئيسيه
معارك تشتد في احياء جنوبيه الخرطوم
مسيرات الجيش تشن غارات على مواقع الدعم
السريع في ام درمان والاتحاد الاوروبي
يدعو الى وقت القتال فورا والتعجيل بجهود
وساطه ويقول ان اي تدخل خارجي سيطيل امد
الصراع في السودان
محطه زفروجيا النوويه محور اتهامات
متبادله بين كلاب وموسكو مخابرات اوكرانيا
تتحدث عن زرع القوات الروسيه متفجرات
تمهيدا لاستهدافها
بعمل تخريبي اوكرانيا
تؤكد ان مفتشيها لم يعثروا على الغام
وتطالب بتوسيع مساحات التفتيش ونائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسيه يقول ان اي حرب يمكن
انهائها اما باتفاق سلام او بالسلاح
النووي
مع تراجع اعمال العنف بين الشرطه الفرنسيه
والمحتجين على خلفيه مقتل شاب برصاص الامن
وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه يقول ان قانون
استخدام الشرطه للسلاح لن يتغير وزيره
المؤسسات الصغرى والمتوسطه تقر في حديث
للجزيره بان الازمه التي شهدتها البلاد
مجتمعيه شبابيه ولا تتعلق بالضواحي وتقول
انما شهدته الاحتجاجات الليليه من ممارسات
لا تظهر بحثا عن حل
[موسيقى]
وفي لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا التوتر والاضطرابات التي
شهدتها صفاقس التونسيه على خلفيه مقتل
مواطن تونسي على يد احد طالبي اللجوء
الافارقه وما اعقبها من تصريحات للرئيس
قيس سعيد دعى فيها السلطات الامن لفرض
القانون
جدد تاكيد على رفض بلاده ان تكون منطقه
عبور او ارضا لتوطين الوافدين عليها من
عدد من الدول الافريقيه لاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي ما تداعيات الجريمه والتوتر الذي
شهدته صفاقس واحد وخمسون في المئه توقعوا
اجراءات حكوميه ضد طالبي اللجوء بينما قال
49% ان الاوضاع متجهه نحو التوتر
والاحتقان هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصوير عبر مسح رمز الذي يظهر الان على
الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه تجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وسنبقى في تونس في فقره في المتابعه في
نهايه الحصاد حيث نتابع صفاقس التونسيه
مسرح توتر عنوانه هو المهاجرون غير
النظاميين بعد مقتل تونسي على يد احد طالب
اللجوء الافارقه وسعيد يدعو سلطات الامن
الى فرض القانون
[موسيقى]
اذا شيعه جنين
اثني عشر شهيدا اليوم هم ضحايا عمليه
عسكريه
اسرائيليه استمرت يومين ووصفتها تل ابيب
بالصعبه المشيعون نددوا بجرائم الاحتلال
وعلى هتافاتهم دعما للمقاومات الفلسطينيه
التي رات في الانسحاب الاسرائيلي فشلا
وعجزا عن تحقيق اهدافه وقد اسفرت العمليه
الاسرائيليه عند دمار كبير في البنى
التحتيه لمخيمه جنين وانقطاعا شبه كلي
للخدمات فيه
عاد الحاج ابو محمد عزايزه وافراد اسرته
الى بيتهم في مخيم جنين بعد اجبارهم على
تركه تحت عزيز الرصاص والصواريخ
الاسرائيليه جراء العمليه العسكريه
الاخيره
ومن شده القصف اضطرينا انه نطلع جينا
طلعنا
وبلغونا انهم ضربوا عنا باب الدار اكثر من
صاروخ ومبينات مبينات اكثر من صاروخ محلهن
وزي ما انت شايف دمار شامل بالبيت دمروا
البيت ودمروا الحاره دمروا السيارات
تهججونا من البيت
التخريب والدمار طالاه ايضا المساجد في
المخيم كمسجد الانصار الذي شهد اعنف
المواجهات المسلحه بين المقاومين
الفلسطينيين وجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
والزيتون
جرافات الاحتلال دمرت شوارع المخيم
وازيقته وكلما كان يعترض طريقها من
ممتلكات الفلسطينيين والحقت اضرارا جسيمه
في قطاعات خدميه واقتصاديه وفي مقدمتها
تدمير شبكات المياه والكهرباء والاتصالات
حزن وغضب من الفلسطينيين خلال تشيعهم اثني
عشر شهيدا سقطوا برصاص وصواريخ جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
هتافات سندت المقاومه الفلسطينيه وطالبتها
بالاستمرار في طريقها لدحر الاحتلال
قتل ودمار وخراب هذا ما خلفته اله الحرب
الاسرائيليه في مخيم جنين عمليه عسكريه
كانت بذريعه القضاء على خلايا الارهاب كما
يزعم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لكن الفلسطينيين
هنا يقولون ان اهداف الاحتلال التي سوقها
لنفسه لم تجد طريقا امام اصرارهم على
مواصله مقاومتهم ومسانده مقاتليها سمير
ابو شماله الجزيره من مخيم جنين فلسطين
اعترض بعض الشبان على مشاركه مسؤولين من
حركه فتح في تشييع جنازه شهداء مخيم جنين
الذين سقطوا خلال مقاومتهم الاجتياح
الاسرائيلي لمدينه جنين ومخيمها خلال
اليومين الماضيين
اذ بدا بعض الشباب بالصراخ مطالبين نائبه
رئيس حركه فتح محمود العلول بعدم القاء
كلمه والمغادره وكان العالون وبرفقته
مسؤولون كبير من فتحهما صبري صيدا وعزام
الاحمد وصلوا الى جنين للمشاركه في عمليه
التشييع ان ثمانيه من الشهداء الاثني عشر
الذين سقطوا هم من كتيبه جنين المشكله من
مقاتلين من سرايا القدس الذراع العسكريه
للجهاد الاسلاميه وكتائب شهداء الاقصى
الذراع العسكريه لحركه فتح
هذا وكان شبان غاضبون في مسيره تشييع
شهداء جنين تجمعوا امام مقر المحافظه في
المدينه ورشق بعضهم المبنى بالحجاره في
حين اطلق الامن الفلسطيني الغاز للمسيله
للدموع على المتظاهرين الغاضبين
قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامينه يهو
ان الجيش وجه ضربه قويه لما وصفه بالارهاب
في مدينه جنين ومخيمها مهددا بعودته بقوه
اكبر اذا عاد اليها الارهاب مره اخرى
واتهم نتنياهو في تصريح له اليوم رجال
المقاومه الفلسطينيه بالهرب من امام قواته
المستعده للعوده وملاحقتهم على حد قوله
واجدد نتنياهو تاكيده بان كل من يحاول
السفك دماء الاسرائيليين سيجد نفسه اما في
القبر او في السجن حسب تعبيره
يرمي كلاسيك يعتقدوا ان مدينه جنين ملجا
لهم لكنها ليست كذلك راينا الابطال الكبار
بين قوسين يهربون بانفسهم من امام قواتنا
واقول لكم هنا اذا عادت جنين الى الارهاب
فسنعود اليها وهذا سيحدث باكبر سرعه ممكنه
وبقوه اكبر واشد مما يعتقدون ومن لا يفهم
هذا اليوم سيفهمه في قادم الايام
عند انطلاق العمليه العسكريه قالت اسرائيل
انها تهدف والاعتقالي وقتلي اكبر عدد من
المقاومين وتدمير مخزون الاسلحه لكن
العمليه انتهت باستشهاد 12 فلسطينيين
وتدمير وتضرري قرابه 80% من الابنيه في
المخيم التفاصيل التفاصيل الاهداف
الاسرائيليه والقوه التي دفع بها جيش
الاحتلال الى جنين والتداعيات والنتائج
نتابعها في هذا التقرير
الجيش الاسرائيلي وصل الى معاقل الفصائل
في جنين ودمر مصنعا لانتاج العبوات
والذخيره العمليه حققت اهدافها يقول وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يؤفكارنت العمليه كانت
صعبه ومعقده وحققت نتائج كبيره يقول
الناطق باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي لتعلق فصائل
المقاومه في جنين بالقول ان المقاومه بخير
والاحتلال فشل في تحقيق اهدافه وفشل في
اعتقال مقاومين والمقاومون اشتبكوا مع جيش
الاحتلال من المسافه صفر فما اهداف
اسرائيل من عمليه جنين والتي تمركزت على
مساحه المخيم اي في نحو كيلو متر مربع
واحد الاهداف الميدانيه تمثلت باعتقال
وقتل اكبر عدد من المقاومين لاحباط عمليات
المقاومه والعمليات المسلحه فيه ضد
اهدافنا استيطانيه واسرائيليه وتدمير
مخزون الاسلحه بحوزه المقاومين وتدمير
منازل وبمن تحتيه بهدف اثاره الشارع
الفلسطيني ضد المقاومين تغيير معالم
المنطقه الجغرافيه بهدف تسهيل اقتحامات
مستقبليه وارضاء حلفاء نتنياهو من تيار
اقصى اليمين
ولتنفيذ هذه الاهداف انشا جيش الاحتلال
قاعده لوجستيه لسلاح المدرعات في مكان
قريب من مسرح العمليات ودفع بنحو الف جندي
من وحدات النخبه واهمها وحده اوغوس ولواء
نحال ووحده دفدفان وهي وحدات كومندس
متخصصه في العمليات البريه اضافه الى
وحدتين ماجلان ويهالوم وهي قوه هندسيه
تتعامل مع تدمير اهداف في عمق اراضي
معاديه ونزع الالغ والكمائن المتفجره كما
استخدمت قوات الاحتلال الاليات الثقيله في
هدم ابنيه في جنين وبحسب صحيفتها اريتس
فان القوه المفرطه التي استخدمها جيش
الاحتلال هي المفاجاه الوحيده في عمليه
جنين اما مفاجات المقاومه فبدات بالقدره
على الاشتباك ل 48 ساعه من قبل عده فصائل
عملت بشكل منفصل عندما تعاملت مع اشتباكات
مباشره
ونسقت ونفذت بشكل مشترك عمليات نوعيه
اضافه لدخول اسلحه اضرت بالقوه المهاجمه
وهي الالغام والعبوات الناسخه انتهت
العمليه باستشهاد 12 فلسطينيا وتدمير كلي
لنحو 300 منزل وتضرر ما بين 400 منزل و500
بشكل جزئي وبرهنه العمليه بحسبها ان
الفلسطينيين قادرون على تنفيذ هجمات
متزامنه واخرى انتقاميه بالاشاره لعمليتي
تل ابيب وبني براك اثناء الهجوم وان اي
عمليه عسكريه لن تتمكن من ايقاف هذه
الرقصه المروعه بحسب وصفها
[موسيقى]
من رام الله ينضم الان الينا دكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه دكتور مصطفى اهلا بك في الحصاد
اذا اسرائيل دخلت مخيم جنين قتلت ودمرت
تكابدت بعض الخسائر ثم خرجت لتجد احتجاجات
في الشارع الاسرائيلي اذا اردنا ان نلخص
الاهداف التي حققتها كما يقول نتنياهو كل
الاهداف تحققت السؤال باي ثمن
اسرائيل لم تحقق الى هدف واحد
انها ارتكبت جريمه حرب جديده على مراه
ومسمع من العالم
وقامت بتدمير البنيه التحتيه لمخيم يقع
تحتلالها
وشنت حربا على شعب مسالم وشعب يعني على
جماهير من المدنيين واجبرت الاف منهم على
الخروج من بيوتهم هذا هو الانجاز الوحيد
لكن لا في انجاز عسكري ولا في انجاز ضد
المقاومه فشلت اسرائيل في اعتقال
المقاومين فشلت في اغتيال المقاومين صحيح
انه في 12 شهيد طبعا قدمتهم المقاومه وجزء
منهم مدن من المدنيين واربعه منهم من
الاطفال
ولكن رغم هذا الثمن الباهظ بالنسبه لنا
الا ان اسرائيل فشلت فشلا ذريعا المقاومه
استمرت لم يهربوا من امام الجيش
الاسرائيلي بل حاربوه حتى اللحظه الاخيره
والجيش الجندي الذي قتل في من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي قتل برصاص المقاومين في اخر
المعركه
وكذلك جرى تفجير العربه في اخر دقائق او
اخر ساعات المعركه الذي جرى صمود رائع
والاهم من كل ذلك ان ظاهره المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تحولت الى ظاهره مقاومه شعبيه
الذي رايته انا بنفسي في جنين امس
التحام جماهيري وحاضنه شعبيه رائعه تلتحم
بالمقاومين المناضلين وجماهير غفيره من
الشباب
مئات والاف الشباب ينضرون في المقاومه بكل
ما يملكون بالتالي الذي جرى انا برايي في
قيمته يقترب من من معادله ما جرى في معركه
الكرامه بمعنى ان الذي يجري الان تحول
شعبي فلسطيني عارم نحو المقاومه ونحو
والتحام بين المقاومه الشعبيه والمقاومه
المسلحه بصوره غير مسبوقه على الاطلاق
والضفه الغربيه كانت في حاله شبه انتفاضه
شع شامله امس في قرى عديده ومدن عديده وفي
داخل القدس نفسها بالعكس نتنياهو لم يحقق
شيئا بل رد في الواقع فشل فشلا ذريعا
وانقلب السحر على الساحر ما حدث هو عكس ما
خططت له اسرائيل بالضبط
وبالاضافه الى ذلك فضحت امام كل الدنيا
باعتبارها مرتكبه لجريمه حرب ولكن انا لا
نستطيع ان ننظر الى الصوره فقط من هذه
الزاويه لابد ايضا ان ننظر اليها من
الزاويه الفلسطينيه تقول المقاومه حققت
نجاحا حققت اثباتا الوجود ربما اكبر من اي
وقت مضى ولكن ماذا عن السلطه هنا هل تلقت
ايضا هذه الرساله هل سنشهد تغييرا في
تعاملها مع المقاومه
هذا ما يجب ان يحدث لانه الرساله الشعبيه
التي سمعها المسؤولون في السلطه
الفلسطينيه اعتقد بصور مختلفه هي رساله
واضحه الشعب يريد وحده وطنيه الشعب يريد
ان يرى قياده وطنيه موحده الشعب يريد ان
تلغى ليس فقط كل اشكال التنسيق الامني بل
ان تلغى كل العقيده الامنيه الخاطئه التي
كرست من خلال اتفاق اسلو بحيث اصبح اصبحت
القوى الامنيه مطالبه بالتنسيق مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي
ومطالبه بان توفر حمايه للاحتلال وهي
عاجزه عن حمايه الشعب الفلسطيني نفسه من
نفس هؤلاء المحتلين ومن نفس المستوطنين
المستعمرين الذين وقامت اسرائيل ايضا
بتوجيه الاهانات الواحده تلو الاخرى
للسلطه الفلسطينيه ما نريده والشعب يريد
وحده وطنيه الغاء هذا التنسيق الامني مره
والى الابد ان يكون هناك تلاحم بين
المكونات الفلسطينيين كلها في قياده وطنيه
موحده وعلى نهج وطني كفاحيا مقاوم وان
يجري الاعتراف في الواقع بان النهج السابق
فشل قتلته اسرائيل مثل ما قتلت اتفاق
اوسلو وكل نهج المفاوضات اشكرك دكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
شكرا لك الان في تداعيات الانسانيه قلى
مكتب الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان ان
الضربات الجويه الاسرائيليه والعمليات
البريه في جنين وما رافقها من قتل واصابه
للمدنيين وتهجير الالاف وتدمير البنى
التحتيه والمنازل قد تشكل جريمه حرب كما
وصف خبراء للامم المتحده الهجمات في الضفه
الغربيه بانها الاعنف منذ تدمير مخيم جنين
عام 2002 كما دعوا للمحاسبه محاسبه
اسرائيل بموجب القانون الدولي على
احتلالها غير الشرعي واعمالها العنيفه
تنضم الان الينا من القدس شينالو ومستشاره
التواصل في المجلس النرويجي للاجئين في
فلسطين
وابدا معك من الوصف بانما جرى في مخيم
جنين هو جريمه حرب هل يؤثر هذا على عملكم
هل توافقون على هذا التوصيف وكيف يؤثر على
عملكم الان بالنسبه لهذه المره والعمليه
التي ارتكبت
في البدايه شكرا جزيلا على هذه الاستضافه
الكريمه اعتقد انه من الاهميه بمكان
وعندما نتحدث عن جرائم الحرب ان نفكر
بالمنظور القانوني الذي يجب ان تعمل وفقه
القوات الاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه وفقا
للقانون الدولي نحن نتحدث عن اضطرابات
داخليه وتوترات داخليه في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله والتي تم توصيفها على
انها افعال منعزله
عنفيه في جنين واماكن اخرى لا ترقى الى
مستوى الاعمال العدائيه لذلك الحكومه
الاسرائيليه يفترض بها ان تطبق قوانين
الاحتلال وقوانين الحرب كجهه انفاذ قانون
وبالتالي
المسموح للقوات الاسرائيليه هو استخدام
القوى فقط في حال كان هناك
واذا ما لم يتم التمكن من التعامل مع هذا
التهديد بطرق الاخرى ما رايناه في جنين في
هذا الاسبوع الضربات الجويه التي تستهدف
المناطق ذات السكنيه الكثافه السكنيه
المرتفعه ما من احد يوافق برايه على ان
هذه العمليه هي عمليه انفاذ قانون ويجب ان
تستمر بالنسبه الى عملنا على مستوى المجلس
النرويجي حيث اعمل حتى الان لم نعمل في
جنين ولكننا نعمل الان مع شركائنا ومع
منظومه الامم المتحده لكي نرى كيف لنا ان
ندعم جهود اعاده الاعمار والاغاثه
الانسانيه في مخيم جنين يعني الوضع في
جنين سيء للغايه لي
ست المرض فيها المخيم لمثل هذه العمليات
ولكن هذه المره ضخامه التدمير
والشبكات الكهرباء والصرف الصحي يعني ربما
تفوق اي مره سابقه والسؤال مع حجم التمويل
الذي يمكن ان يرصد لاعاده الحياه على
الاقل لحد ادنى للمواطنين الذين تضرروا
بهذا الشكل
ان منظومه الامم المتحده تعمل مع الجهات
المانحه من اجل جمع التمويل في حالات
الطوارئ مع منظمات انسانيه هناك عمل
للوصول الى صناديق
الاستفاده منها يتم في حاله الطوارئ ونحن
على مستوى مجلس النرويجي نحاول ان ننظر في
ذلك طبعا هذا يضغط على القطاع الانساني
والاغاثي الذي يعاني اصلا من ازمه تمويل
هنا في فلسطين هناك حاجه ملحه ليس فقط في
الضفه الغربيه بل ايضا في قطاع غزه الى
التمويل وهناك تراجع في تمويل الكلاس
الامم المتحده كالاذن وغيرها
الوضع ليس فقط سيئا في جنين وانما في كافه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه خصوصا بعد ما جاء
حكومه الائتلاف العنصريه المتطرفه بعد سته
اشهر من اداء هذه الحكومه هل رصدتم حجم
الانتهاكات التي ارتكبت
نراه هو انه في العام 2023 هي السنه
التاريخيه او القياسيه بالنسبه الى
انتهاكات في الضفه الغربيه المحتله مع هذه
العمليه الاخيره في جنين عدد الفلسطينيين
الذين قتلوا في الجزء الاول من السنه وصل
الى عدد الفلسطينيين الذين قتلوا في كل
العام في السنه الماضيه في الضفه الغربيه
152 فلسطين بما في ذلك ثمانيه وعشرين طفل
ولقد راينا ذلك تزايدا في عنف المستوطنين
اكثر من مئه او حوالي 100 احاديث في الجزء
الاول او النصف الاول من السنه بالمقارنه
مع السنه الماضيه وهذه الحوادث تحصل بشكل
متكرر وبحجم اكبر عدد من المستوطنين غالبا
ما يكونون بحمايه من القوات الاسرائيليه
يجتمعون مع بعضهما او في بعض الاحيان
بمشاركه مع القوات الاسرائيليه شكرا جزيلا
مستشاره التواصل في المجلس النرويجي
للاجئين في فلسطين شكرا
لان الى موضوع اخر اصيب عدد من المحتاجين
الاسرائيليين خلال قيام مركبات اسرائيليه
باختراق مكان تجمع المحتاجين في شارع
ايلون وسط تل ابيب اذ اظهرت مقاطع فيديو
قيام مركبات باختراق التجمع
ودهسي مجموعه من المحتاجين فيما افادت
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه بقيام الشرطه
الاسرائيليه باستخدام القوه لتفريق
المتظاهرين وتاتي التحركات احتجاجا على
خطه الحكومه لاجراء تعديلات في الجهاز
القضائي وتشاهدونه الان هي صور حيه
للعمليه ومحاولات الانقاذ
وسنادا لمنظمي الاحتجاجات فان قرار
الحكومه باجراء التعديلات سيحرم
الاسرائيلي الاسرائيليين من حريه الراي
والتعبير وسيحد من الحياه الديمقراطيه في
حين تقول الحكومه الاسرائيليه انها تهدف
لاصلاح جهاز القضاء في اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
اذا واضح ان هناك محاولات لتفريق
المتظاهرين بالقوه هذا ما نشاهده الان على
الشاشه هناك مركبات ايضا امنيه رسميه
عسكريه ايضا في مكان تواجد هؤلاء
المتظاهرين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
طبعا اللافت ان هذا هذه الاحتجاجات تاتي
بعد نحو 24 ساعه من انتهاء العمليه التي
كانت اسرائيل قد بداتها في مخيم جنين
والتي قالت انها حققت اهدافها
ولكن طبعا هذه الاحتجاجات تعود بهذه
السرعه والمعروف ان الداخل الاسرائيلي كان
قد اظهر احتجاجا وانتقادا لاداء الحكومه
الائتلافيه في وقت سابق وكانت هناك
محاولات كثيره ربما لصرف الانظار
ولعل العوده بهذه الصوره السريعه تدل على
عدم رضا داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي بشكل عام
على اداء الحكومه ومن ضمنها ربما ما حصل
بالامس
[موسيقى]
وكما هو معروف فان هذه الاحتجاجات تقوم
بسبب اداء الحكومه الائتلافيه فيما يتعلق
بالقضاء الاسرائيلي ولكن بشكل عام لا يمكن
تجاوز ان هذه الاحتجاجات تعود فقط بعد يوم
من انتهاء العمليه بهذه السرعه وكان هناك
ايضا رساله من الداخل الاسرائيلي لهذه
الحكومه وعلى راسها بنيامين نتالياهو
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره بوقوع
اطلاق نار كثيف من اسلحه ثقيله حول احياء
الرميله والحله الجديده والمنطقه الصناعيه
غربيه الخرطوم تزامنا مع تحليق للطيران
الحربي في سماء العاصمه وفي ام درمان قال
الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني نبيل عبد الله
للجزيره الى العمليات العسكريه تسير وفق
الخطه المعده وانها حققت نجاحا كبيرا كما
افاد شهد عيان بان الجيش يواصل تمشيط
مدينه ام درمان مستخدما الاسلحه الثقيله
والخفيفه مع اشراك القوات الخاصه لاخراج
افراد الدعم السريع من داخل منازل
المواطنين
هو صوت الغالب على المشهد
من معارك الخرطوم الضاريه ما يدور الى
جنوبها وغربها
تشهد ام درمان عمليات للجيش السوداني يقول
انها حققت نجاحا كبيرا في عملياته التلك
اشرك الجيش قوته الخاصه في تنشيط المدينه
لتطويق ما سماه التمرد فيها ولقطع الطرق
امداده
في اجواء الخرطوم بحري تحتدم معارك من نوع
اخر تستمر البيانات والبيانات المضاده عن
اسقاط مسيرات وطائرات حربيه
قبل ايام اعلنا الجيش اسقاط مسيره لقوات
الدعم السريع وها هو الدعم ينشر صورا يقول
انها لحقام الطائره للجيش السوداني من
طراز ميج اسقطتها قواته خلال معارك
الخرطوم بحري
ما عدا القتال الذي اندلع في منتصف ابريل
الماضي حكرا على مثلث الخرطوم الخرطوم
بحري ام درمان الى الجنوب تجدد القصف
المدفعي والاشتباكات العنيفه في مدينه
الاوبيض مركز ولايه شمال كردفان ولا يبدو
الوضع اقل التهابا في ولايه دارفور بغربي
السودان حيث يتعقد الصراع بحسابات اثنيه
وقبليه بل ان المخاوف تتعاظم من امتداد
الحرب الى شمال البلاد وشرقها
اليس اذا من افق للحل نائب رئيس مجلس
السياده عزا اخيرا فشل وقف اطلاق النار
لافتقاره لاليات التنفيذ الصحيحه كان مالك
عقار يتحدث عن واحده من وساطات يخشى انها
انتهت جميعا الى حاله من الياس الاقليمي
والدولي المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه التي
افرزت اعلان جده علقت اخيرا بعد اقرارها
جمله من الهدى ساميه المؤقته سرعان ما
انتهكها طرفا النزاع في السودان الامم
المتحده التي لم تحقق بعثتها اي اختراق
لازمه السودان تقر بان اي جهود لن تكون
كافيه حتى تؤدي الى وقف اطلاق نار مستدام
ودائم اما مبادره الاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه
ايجاد في هذا الصدد فاصطدمت بتحفظات
الخرطوم ورفضها
فالسودان معلقه عضويته في الاتحاد
الافريقي بينما يصف ما طرحته دول ايجاد
بانها مبادره احتلال قبل ايام اكد رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
قبول بلاده باي مبادره تركيه لايقاف الحرب
واحلال السلام
وقبله اشار نائبه الى طلب السودان مساعده
روسيا في حل النزاع في السودان لكن لا شيء
جديدا طرح حتى الان لا من هذا الطرف ولا
من ذلك وبينما تدخل المساعد دبلوماسيه
مرحله من الخمول تستمر محنه السودان انها
تتعقد وتطول
هذا ودانا الاتحاد الاوروبي بشده القتال
الدائر في السودان واستمرار رفض اطراف
النزاع السعيا الى حل سلمى وقال الاتحاد
الاوروبي في بيان ان الهجمات الواسعه على
المدنيين في السودان وفتح جبهات قتال
جديده في جنوب كردفان امر مثير للقلق وشدد
الاتحاد الاوروبي على ضروره القيام بجهود
وساطه من اجل وقف دائما لاطلاق النار
لضمان حمايه شعب السودان دون تاخير كما
اضاف الاتحاد الاوروبي ان اي تدخل خارجي
سيطيل امد الصراع في السودان ويهدد الوضع
الانساني ويقوض الاستقرار الاقليمي
ويسعدني ان يكون معي هنا في الاستوديو
دكتور اسامه عيدروس الاكاديمي السوداني
المختص في الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه اهلا
وسهلا بك دكتور اسامه اذا الى اين تتجه
الامور بعد كل هذه المحاولات من جهات
مختلفه للتدخل الحسم العسكري هل يبدو له
افق الان
في الحقيقه الصراع نفسه يعني منذ ان بدا
تحور كثيرا لذلك انا عندما اسمع انه ليس
هنالك من جهود حقيقيه لايقاف الحرف في
السودان هذا الكلام صحيح لانه كل طبيعه
المبادرات التي جاءت لايقاف هذا الصراع لا
تفهم انه هنالك اكثر من حرب في السودان
ليست حربا واحده يعني بدايه الحرب في يوم
15 ابريل طبيعتها تغيرت كثيرا الان وحتى
الحديث عن جنوب كردفان الحديث عن دارفور
يفترض انه عندما يتم الحديث عنها يكون
عارفين ان هذا يعني حرب مختلفه ليس بنفس
الحرب التي تدور في الخرطوم مقوله
الحسم العسكري هذه منذ البدايه تم اتخاذه
يعني الكثير من من
المراقبين الدوليين يتحدثون عن عدم
امكانيه الحسم العسكري
وفورا يتم الصغار معها التدخل الدولي من
اجل حمايه المدنيين هذه ظلت نغمه سائده
لكن المراقب للحرب ان الجيش منذ ان استطاع
امتصاص الصدمه الاولى بعد 15 ابريل
استطاع التعامل مع تغيرات الحرب
بينما الدعم السريع في المقابل يعني من
110 من قوات النخبه المجربه جيدا المسلحه
تسليح عالي ذو كثافه ايرانيه عاليه اليوم
في الخرطوم لا يستطيع ان يشن هجومي في يوم
واحد على موقع عسكري من الجيش وحتى
المواقع التي يختارها للهجوم الان هي
مواقع الشرطه العسكريه وليست معسكرات
الجيش كبيره ولكن ايضا هناك اطراف اخرى
دخلت على المشهد اتوسعت فلذلك حتى لو لم
يكن يتمكن من فعل ذلك داخل الخرطوم في
النهايه القضيه لن تحسم فقط بهذه الموازنه
الذي قلتها ان هنالك عده حروب يعني مثلا
الدعم السريع في دارفور منذ التفجر الحرب
في البدايه دخل قاده الدعم السريع
الموجودين في دارفور في تفاهمات وهدنه
قامت بها المكونات المحليه
المخرج الان هو ان نفهم هذا الصراع اذا
تحدثنا عن الحسمة العسكري فهو قادم الجيش
متقدم بقوه على الارض
ويمكنه حسم هذه المعركه العسكريه لكن
الحرب اوسع الحرب تتطلب انه القاده
السياسيين في السودان يقدموا مبادره
سياسيه اسمى من مصالحهم واجندتهم الخاصه
مبادره همها الاول المواطن السوداني
المدني الذي تضرر كثيرا الجميع كما قلت
تعقيد هذا الامر المشكله ان هناك مواطنين
كثر يعانون ويدفعون ثمنا غاليا اشكرك
جزيلا دكتور اسامه عيدروس شكرا
[موسيقى]
نعاود الان
الى محطه او للحرب الاوكرانيه ومحطه
زباروجيا النوويه تعود الى واجهه المشهد
في الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا مع تبادل
الطرفين الاتهامات بالتخطيط لاستهداف
المحطه والحاق اضرار بها غير ان القول
الفصل يبقى للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
التي قال مديرها ان خبراء الوكاله فتشوا
اجزاء من منشاه المحطه ولم يجدوا اي دلائل
على وجود الغام او متفجرات لكنه طالب في
الوقت ذاته بتوسيع مساحات التفتيش
مره اخرى تعود المحطه النوويه في زابروجيا
مسرحا لالقاء الاتهامات بين موسكو وكيف
الجانب الاوكراني اتهم لجانب الروسي بزرع
ما قال انها مواد تشبه المتفجرات على اسطح
وحدات للطاقه
بدورها موسكو حذرت من عمل تخريبي اوكراني
قد يستهدف المحطه لا بل ان الشركه الروسيه
للطاقه النوويه حددت موعدا كانت الخامس من
الشهر الجاري لما قالت انه هجوم اوكراني
على المحطه النوويه بالمدفعيه والمسيرات
وسط سيل الاتهامات بين الجانبين ياتي نفي
اولي من الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
بعدم وجود اي متفجرات حتى الان
خبراء الوكاله فتشوا اجزاء من محطه
لكنهم بحاجه لمعينه كافه المنشات لتاكيد
نهائي لما وصلوا اليه استنادا لتصريح
مديرها العام
بعيدا عن مخاطر الاستهداف المتعمد تعمل
المحطه التي سيطرت عليها روسيا مع بدايه
حربها وسط تحديات متكرره يتعلق اكثرها
بتجهيزات عمل المحطه نفسها
قبل ايام تم توصيل خط الكهرباء الاحتياطي
بعد توقفه لاربعه اشهر كانت المحطه خلالها
تغذى من خط خارجي واحد لتبريد المفاعل
وغيره مما يطلق عليها مستلزمات الامان
النووي
واجهت المحطه سبعه قطاعات لمصادر الطاقه
الخارجيه منذ بدء الحرب وفق المدير العام
لوكاله الطاقه الذريه ايضا انخفاض منسوب
مياه البحيره الناتج عن تفجير سدق خوفكا
الشهر الماضي ميدان مواجهه والاتهام ينطوي
على مغامره كبيره تتعدى حدود الجغرافي
الاوكرانيه فروسيا تسيطر على المحطه لكن
قواتها تواجه في الوقت نفسه هجوما
اوكرانيا مكثفا في جبهه مقاطعه زابروجيا
اما اوكرانيا التي بريت المحطه على ارضها
فتنتج لها خمس حاجتها من الكهرباء لكنها
في الوقت نفسه قد ينظر اليها كورقه ضغط
دولي العاصمه ضد روسيا لا شك ان هذه
المحطه النوويه الاكبر في اوروبا والعاشره
على مستوى العالم تبدو الان كقنبله موقوته
فاي تسرب نجاعي فان تاثيره سيصل الى مئات
الكيلومترات في اوروبا وروسيا ما يعني
انتفاء امكانيه الحياه في نطاق الانتشار
ربما لعقود طويله مع ما يرافق ذلك من
امراض مميته مثل السرطان وتشوهات المواليد
كما حدث في مفاعل باوكرانيا في 8 نيات
القرن الماضي
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي فان اي حرب
يمكن انهائها بسرعه اما باتفاق سلام او
باستخدام السلاح النووي واضاف ان النيتو
اذا ما توقف عن مد اوكرانيا بالسلاح
لانتهت العمليه العسكريه في غضون ايام على
حد قوله
اذا توقف الناتو ولا سيما من ولاياته
المتحده واتباعها عن امداد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه ووسائل التدمير فان العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه ستنتهي في غضون ايام
قليله يمكن انهاء اي حرب وذلك اما بتوقيع
معاهده سلام او كما فعل الامريكيون في عام
1945 حين استخدموا اسلحتهم النوويه وقصفوا
اليابانيين
ومن بيروت ينضم الان الينا العميد الياس
حناء الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ومن باريس الدكتور هول دورسنان خبير
الطاقه النوويه في مركز ابحاث السياسات
العلميه في جامعه البريطانيه ورئيس
المجموعه الدوليه للاستشارات النوويه اهلا
وسهلا بكما ابدا معك عميد الياس حنا فيما
يتعلق بهذه الاتهامات المتبادله بين
الطرفين الروسي والاوكراني بشان محطه سفرو
جيا ما واقعيه هذه السيناريوهات استهداف
هذه المحطه
والاثر والضرر الكبير الذي يخشاه كثيرون
ليلى اي حدث في هذه المحطه هو خاسر خاسر
للفريقين يعني هي من يقول انها ملكيته وهو
الاوكراني هو يقاتل في جوانبها ومن يقول
ان بعض ضمها المرسوم ضم الاربعه اقاليم من
الرئيس بوتين اذا تعرضت المحطه الى شيء
معين الى حدث مهم هو المتضرر الاساسي
اليوم منهم من يقارنها بتفجير
سدوفكا وهذا الامر مختلف تماما اليوم لا
احد يتحدث عن تفجير السد بينما اذا لا سمح
الله حدثت هذه
الحادثه قد تؤثر الى فترات طويله وسنوات
طويله على كل الاجزاء ضمنا الجيش
الاوكراني والجيش الروسي لو سلمنا جدلا ان
الجبهه انهارت والجيش الروسي انهارا
باكمله وبدا الانسحاب بالاتجاه الحدود
روسيه قد يلجا
الرئيس بوتين الى تفعيل العقيده النوويه
التي تقول التصعيد لخفض التصعيد واستعمال
النووي التكتيكي ولكن لا اعتقد في هذا
الوضع ان الامر يتجاوز التهديدات
والتهديدات المباشره ليلى اذا ترى ان كل
هذه العمليات وهذه الاتهامات بين الطرفين
هي مجرد ربما اثاره البلبله الاعلاميه لا
اكثر ولا اقل ام هناك شيء من الحقيقه في
هذه التحقيقات او
التهديدات اولا تفجير تفجير المحطه بوجود
رقابه دوليه وكاله الطاقه الذريه التي
قالت لا يوجد اي شيء ولكن انا اعتقد اليوم
ان المرحله القادمه هي مرحله شد الحبال
والتوقيت هو توقيت
الهجوم النووي الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
وبالتالي هي عمليه من ضمن العمليات كم مره
تم الحديث عن تفجير قنبله قذره الخطوره في
هذه المحطه انه ما
2200 طن من السبنتيول كما يقال لنا من
الفيول المستعمل والتخزين موجود قد يؤدي
الى قنبله قذره ولكن هذه القنبله القذره
ليلى هي المتضرر هو الجيش الاوكراني
والجيش الروسي ولكن هل الجيش الروسي معد
للقتال في اجواء رضيشن او اشعاعات او نويه
الجيش الروسي اليوم لا يستطيع تامين
اللوجستيه لا يستطيع ليس لديه الاليات
الحديثه انا اعتقد لا احد مجهز لهكذا حرب
انها عمليه يعني عرض الاصابع والاتهام
والاتهام انه بادل ومحاوله نسخ صوره الاخر
شكرا جزيلا لك العميد الياس حنا لا ننتقل
الى ضيفي
من باريس اذا هذه التحذيرات وفي النهايه
في كل مره يكون هناك محطه نوويه في قلب
مثل هذه التهديدات
يخشى الجميع من كارثه نوويه ولكن حقيقه في
محطه سبروجيا هل هناك مثلا تركيبه معينه
بحيث يمكن الحاق الضرر عسكريا بجزء من هذه
المحطه دون ان تؤدي الى المخاوف النوويه
التي يخشاها الكل
لم يشتغل
والسين اود ان ابدا بالقول ان ما نراه ولا
ربما للمره الاولى هو احتمال وجود هجوم
عسكري يستهدف منشاه نوويه
قيد العمل ان
المنشاه لا يعني اذا ما كانت غير عامله او
الى مكان المفاعل غير شغال هذا لا يعني ان
المنشاه لم تعد خطره وبالتالي هناك حاجه
لتبريدها وهناك حاجه لصيانتها هذا لديه
تداعيات اساسيه على المستوى النووي ليس
فقط في اوكرانيا بل في كل ارجاء العالم
لانه في عالم يزداد فيه انعدام الاستقرار
السؤال المطروح بالنسبه الى امن المنشات
النوويه هو السؤال الاساسي ولكن هل من
مصلحه روسيا وهي التي تسيطر على هذه
المحطه فعلا ان تلحق بها الاضرار التي
يتحدث عنها الجانب الاوكراني
وما نوع الاضرار التي يمكن ان تحدث في هذه
المرحله برايك
لست خبيرا عسكريا استراتيجيا عسكريا انا
تخصصي يرتبط بالطاقه النوويه والاشعاعات
ولكن الحقيقه كما يراها الجميع هي ان
روسيا تتصرف بطريقه سيئه وقامت بارتكاب
سلسله من الاخطاء في الحروب الامور لا
تسير دائما كما هو مخطط هذا ما نعرفه
النقطه الاساسيه بالنسبه الى مجال الطاقه
النوويه من دون تبريد
نشط للمنشاه النوويه كما حصل في فوكوشيما
على سبيل المثال هذا يؤدي الى سلسله من
الاحداث وتفجر
وهناك انهيار يؤدي الى تبعات خطيره نحن
نتحدث عن سته مفاعل
المحطه الاكبر محطه النوويه الاكبر في
اوروبا هذا ما هو عليه المنشاه فيزا اذا
ما النهار نظام التبريد سوف يؤدي ذلك الى
النتيجه تظهر بعد يوم
ويومين وبكلمات اخرى يكون لدينا انهيار
للمنشاه لذلك يجب ان يؤخذ ذلك على محمل
الجد من منظوري الحمايه الاشعاعيه شكرا
جزيلا لك
خبير الطاقه النوويه في مركز الابحاث
السياسات العلميه في جامعه ساس [__] كنت
معنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
لاني لا تداعياتي الاضطرابات التي شهدتها
فرنسا مؤخرا على خلفيه مقتل شاب برصاص
الامن اذ قال وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه جلال
ان قانون عام 2017 المنظم لاستخدام
الاسلحه الناريه من قبل سلطات انفاذ
القانون لن يتغير واكد دارمينا ان الشرطه
لا تطلق النار حاليا اكثر من السابق واضاف
الوزير الفرنسي في رد على اعضاء مجلس
الشيوخ انعدم احترامي ضابط شرطه للقانون
لا يعني بالضروره تغيير بلوده
ووصف الامر بانه سخيف
وقد وصفت الوزيره المنتدبه المكلفه
بالمؤسسات الصغرى والمتوسطه لتجاره
والمتحدثه السابقه باسم الحكومه الفرنسيه
اوليفيا
وصفت الاحداث التي وقعت في فرنسا بالازمه
المجتمعيه ورفضت وصفها بازمه الضواحي
وقالت في مقابله مع الجزيره الى الامن
مستتب في فرنسا وان الهدوء قد عاد ونمر
شهدته الاحتجاجات الليليه من ممارسات لا
تظهر بحثا عن حل
الازمه ليست ازمه ضواحي بل نتحدث عن ازمه
مجتمعيه شبابيه كانت الازمه قصيره للغايه
خمسه ايام وفي عطله نهايه الاسبوع اقول
بكل سعاده ان النظام مستتب في فرنسا وعاد
الهدوء وفرنسا امنه نحن لا نشهد ازمه
ضواحي بل اعمالا على مستوى الشباب وليست
في الضواحي
يسد هدوء مدينه صفاقس في تونس بعد ليله
شهدت احتجاجات وقطع طرق عاقبه مقتل تونسي
على يد احد طالبين اللجوء الافارقه وقد
قام خلال الليله الماضيه محتاجون غاضبون
من اهالي المدينه بملاحقه عدد من طالب
اللجوء كما قطع اخرون الطريق الرابطه بين
محافظتي صفاقس والمهديه وعقب هذه الاحداث
دعا الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد قوه الامن
الى تطبيق القانون وقال ان تونس لن تقبل
ان يقيم على ارضها الا من يلتزم بقانونها
ولا تقبل بان تكون منطقه عبور او ارض
توطين للوافدين من دول افريقيه وفق تعبيره
هذا وقد غادر عدد كبير من طالبي اللجوء
الافارقه مدينه صفاقس متجهين الصوب
العاصمه تونس واعلب اعلن نائب البرلمان
التونسي عن مدينه صفاقس ان نحو 1000 من
طالبي اللجوء غادروا البلاد عبر الحدود مع
كل من ليبيا والجزائر ومن جانبه اعتبر
المنتدى الفرنسي او المنتدى التونسي
بالاحرى للحقوق الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه ان
ترحيلها هؤلاء الافارقه امر مهين
ومخالف للتزامات تونس الدوليه وفق تعبيره
لهذا الموضوع نسلط الضوء في هذه الفقره
على ازمه طالبي اللجوء من دول افريقيه في
تونس والجهود الاوروبيه للحد من وصول
قوارب الهجره الى اراضيها يستخدم معظم
طالبي اللجوء الممر البحري من الشواطئ
التونسيه نحو القاره الاوروبيه مستغلين
قرب المسافه التي لا تتجاوز في بعض النقاط
150 كيلومترا بين تونس وجزيره لمبيدوزا
الايطاليه
ولوقف هذه الاعداد من طالبي اللجوء يدرس
قاده الاتحاد الاوروبي اقتراحا يشمل منحه
تونس مساعده ماليه طويله الامد بقيمه 900
مليون يورو ومساعده بقيمه 150 مليون يتم
صرفها فورا في الميزانيه وحزمه بقيمه 105
ملايين لاداره الهجره في العام الجاي
ويعتزم الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا منح تونس
قوارب وردرات نقاله وكاميرات وعربات
لمساعدتها في تعزيز ضبط حدودها البريه
والبحريه كما يتولى الاتحاد تمويل العوده
الطوعيه لطالبي اللجوء من دول افريقيا
جنوب الصحراء وذلك عبر تونس الى بلادهم
ووفق المفاوضات الاوروبيه يمول التكتل
وقد سجل الجانب الايطالي ايضا زياده
ملحوظه في اعداد طالبي اللجوء الوافدين
الى شواطئه تجاوز عددهم 60 الف شخص منذ
مطلع هذا العام وذلك وفق المفوضيه الساميه
للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
هذا العرض الاوروبي جاء خلال زياره لتونس
قامت بها رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل
ورئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه ونظرها الهولندي
مارك
لا تزال هذه المباحثات متعثره بسبب موقف
بعض اعضاء الاتحاد الاوروبي من الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد ووضع حقوق الانسان
كما ترتبط المساعده الاوروبيه في جزء منها
بالمفاوضات المستمره مع صندوق النقد
الدولي وتونس وذلك لمنح الاخيره قرضا
مشروطا بقيمه ملياري دولار
في المقابل يشدد الرئيس التونسي على ان
بلاده لن تكون حارسه لحدود اوروبا ولن
تخضع لاملاءات صندوق النقد حسب قبوله
وتنضم الان الينا من تونس نسرين بن بلقاسم
الباحثه في علم الاجتماع وشؤون الهجره
وعضو المنتدى التونسي للحقوق الانسانيه
والاجتماعيه اهلا وسهلا بك سيدة نسرين اذا
رغم شكرا اهلا وسهلا بك رغم كل الاتفاقات
التي ابرمتها تونس والتي وقعتها مع جهات
مختلفه ولكنها تواجه هذه المشكله مع
اللاجئين اليها ما هي ما حجم المشكله
حقيقه ولماذا تستمر رغم كل ما تم التوصل
اليه خصوصا بوساطه ونشاط ايطالي واضح
هو فعلا اليوم نحن نعيش ازمه في تونس خاصه
بعلاقه المواطنين في تونس
طالبي اللجوء خاصه الجنسيات
الفرقه جنوب الصحراء وهذا يعود اولا لعدم
الوصول الى اتفاق او حلول جدريه
وايجاد حلول للحد اولا من ظاهره النظاميه
او ايجاد حلول المهاجرين الافارقه جنوب
الصحراء لانهم يعيشون في تونس
يبحثون عن اللجوء ويطلبون اللجوء ولكن لم
يتمكنوا من ذلك في تونس وخاصه ان الدول
الاوروبيه تقوم بالضغط على الدوله
التونسيه من اجل خدمه مصالحها الخاصه
والحد من الهجره النظاميه بالنسبه اليها
وتستغل الظروف الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه الهشه تونس
وتقوم بالابتزاز نوعا ما وذلك لخدمه
مصلحتها الخاصه ولكن يعني هل خرجت الامور
عن السيطره لدرجه تدفع الرئيس نفسه لكي
يتساءل من اين ياتي هؤلاء ولماذا ياتون
الى صفاقس تحديدا وما الى ذلك اذا كان
يعني الامور الحكومه نفسها تجد ان وهي
تتمتع والرئيس نفسه ويتمتع بكل الصلاحيات
لا يستطيع ايجاد اجابات على هذه الاسئله
وحتى حلول اين نقف من حل حقيقي
نوعا ما هناك عجز من قبل يعني الدوله
التونسيه للحد من هذه الازمه لان هذه
الازمه يعني نلاحظ ان في ارتفاع
وتتعمق كثيرا خاصه نجد ان لقد الصفحه التي
يعني ظهرت العنف ووصلت حتى للقتل ونعلم
جيدا انه هناك يعني تونسي يعني تم قتله من
قبل
المهاجرين الافارقه جنوب الصحراء المسلمين
في منطقه
صفاقس وخاصه انها يعني هذه الازمه تتعمق
يوم بعد يوم ولكن هناك عجز من قبل الدوله
التونسيه في ايجاد حلول جذريه لانها لن من
الحصول على اتفاق مع الدول الاوروبيه
وخاصه انها في موضع للابتزاز وعدم وجود
حلول جذريه للحد من هذه الظاهره طيب ما
نوع الاتفاق الذي يمكن ان يحصل ويمكن ان
يشكل مخرجا لتونس مثلا وليس فقط لتونس
لغيرها من الدول التي تعاني ايضا من مشكله
حقيقيه
هي بالنسبه
جميع الدول وخاصه ان تونس اصبحت منطقه
عبور لعديد من الجنسيات ليس فقط لافارقه
جنوب الصحراء نظر نجد كذلك جنسيه اخرى
سوريا
الجزائر ولكن لا نعلم لماذا تونس هي
الدوله الوحيده التي تتحمل مسؤوليه ظهيره
الهجره النظاميه بهذه الظاهره تموس العديد
من الدول
سواء كانت من المغرب العربي او من الجنوب
افريقيا لماذا تونس هي الدوله الوحيده
التي تتحمل هذه المسؤوليه اين رؤساء الدول
الاخرى يعني
لتكون الحل الجذري يجب ان تتوافق جميع
الجهود والدول والرؤساء الدول الاخرى لا
يجب على تونس ان تتحمل المسؤوليه وحدها
وخاصه نعلم اننا في وضع اقتصادي هش اشكرك
نسرين بن بلقاسم الباحثه في علم الاجتماع
وشؤون الهجره وعضو المنتدى التونسي للحقوق
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه من تونس شكرا
جزيلا لك
اذا بهذا ينتهي الحصاد هذه الليله